when the Doom claimed valyria the great
freeh hole fractured into Waring cities
and upstart Nations ripe for the taking
out of the East swarmed the Dothraki the
horse Lords of the Plains who feared
only defeat and dragons and now the
dragons were all gone under the great
carteo they sacked and burnt every town
and city in their
path no Army could stand against them
because the dothi do not stand the horse
Lords do not draw up battle lines or
hide behind Shield walls or lay
themselves in armor the dothi charge
their blades are more syy than sword the
better to Cull the Infantry ranks
without breaking stride even their
archers fire from horseback so that
advancing or retreating the arrows never
cease to the daki a man who does not
ride is no man at all without honor or
Pride for free you can now listen to the
entire audiobook Fire and Blood blood on
which house of the Dragon is based and
which covers the entire targaryan
history including current and future
events of House of the Dragon for free
with a notable trial using our Link in
the
description when the city of Kor
realized CER was coming they
strengthened their walls doubled their
own guards and hired two full companies
of cell swords the dothi were used to
glorified Farmers with Spears quo would
show them a proper army with mounted and
armored Cavalry to match the hord's own
as an afterthought the city leaders sent
an Envoy to asapur to buy
unsullied the slavers had always claimed
that the unsullied were the Great gari
Legions come again few cared the dragon
burnt ruins of old geese were a stark
reminder that the age of the foot
soldier was over the envoy had his
orders however and quickly bought 3,000
unsullied for the long Marge back for
unsullied do not
ride but while they marched cteu arrived
at
quall I can imagine how pleased the Carl
was to finally face a challenge by the
end of the battle crows and wolves
feasted on what remained of Coor's heavy
horse all the cell swords had fled quor
knew that the Dothraki would very soon
break through the gates to rape slave
and burn at their
pleasure yet the next day car temo woke
to find before the gates 3,000 Unix in
formation armed with only Spears Shields
and spiked Helms the unsullied had
slipped past the K's Army in the night
while the Dothraki
feasted cteo had many times their number
and could easily have flanked the small
Force but to the Dothraki men on foot
are fit only to be written
down 18 times the horse Lords charged
and 18 times the unsullied locked their
ship Shields lowered their Spears and
held the line against 20,000 dothi
screamers when the Carl's archers rained
arrows on them the unsullied lifted
their Shields above their heads until
the Squall
passed and then they held the
line in the end only 600 unsullied
remained but more than 12,000 Dothraki
lay dead including Carl T and all his
sons the new Carl led the survivors past
The City Gate Gates where one by one
each man cut off his braid and threw it
down before the feet of the unsullied
defeated and shamed
forever since that day the unsullied
fill the ranks of cities and households
wealthy enough or desperate enough cell
swords fight for gold Knights for Glory
and Dothraki for blood to a man the
unsullied fight only to
obey with the right Master over them
imagine how the forces of chaos would
break against their
Shields the conquerors the Mad Men the
usurpers between the free cities and the
bones between the Shivering sea and
slavers Bay spreads the dothi sea name
not for its Waters but for how freely
its conquerors roam upon it a traveler
on the dothi sea will find few Villages
and no Farms because the Dothraki view
it is a sin to cut into their mother
Earth with plows and shovels and the
Dothraki know only one
punishment the closest the Dothraki
approach to civilization is vice dothrak
though to Outsiders it doesn't look like
a city there are no walls because the
daki believe only cowards hide behind
them instead of facing an enemy blade in
hand but the daraki couldn't do that
here either within the bounds of the
city no one not even the mightiest car
may carry a blade by order of the
priestesses of the Do khim Not that any
enemy would be foolish enough to attack
the Sacred City of the DOI in the first
place two giant bronze stallions rear
over the entrance to the city their
Hooves meeting in the air to form an
arch the famous horse gate through it is
the God's way where the Dothraki drag
the sacred Idols of the cities and
peoples they've broken along one side
Stone gods look down on you from C
Thrones with chipped and stained faces
their names lost to time across the road
monsters watch you pass black Iron
dragons with jewels For Eyes roaring
Griffins manticor with Barb Tails poised
to strike and other terrible beasts from
every corner of
os but there is nothing to fear if these
gods and Devils had any power they would
never have ended here not all foreign
gods in Vio Rak are broken in the famous
eastern and western markets Merchants
worship their God of trade with the
sufferance of the daraki who themselves
don't understand buying and selling the
Western Market is a great square of
beaten Earth filled with animal pens
drinking halls and a maze of stores and
crooked aisles even goods from westros
find their way here though the merchants
who sell them wouldn't know A Lannister
from AF Fray the Eastern Market is
fittingly a strange
place the Elders of the do khen view it
with suspicion and most Dothraki stay
away they aren't wrong the great
elephants the basilisks and silver cages
and the striped black and white horses
of the yogus Nai are harmless enough but
I can see how the elders wouldn't want
their younger members to see the warrior
Maids of hakun who wear iron rings in
their nipples and rubies in their cheeks
or listen to The shadowmen Who cover
their bodies with tatos and hide their
faces behind masks and Whisper dark
secrets for a
price this is all a vice doth rack that
foreigners ever know for only doth raki
are permitted into the inner city where
the do khen live out their lives a blood
Rider drunk on fermented Mar's milk once
told me that the do Ken are stewards
they prepare for the day when every
Rider of every cisar shall return to the
city and the Dothraki truly will be one
blood and one kisar again under the
greatest Carl of all the stallion who
mounts the world he will ride to the
ends of the Earth and grind Nations into
dust and take the whole world as his
herd or so the prophecy
goes yet the world is vast with many
places a horse can't go the stallion who
mounts the world couldn't rear above a
mountain range or leap across the sea
still the world has been conquered
before
just not with
stallions the Doom took valyria in
minutes but the rest of esos wasn't so
lucky out of be swarm the dothi and
there were no dragons to push them back
the Dothraki tide slammed first into the
sori who called themselves the tall men
and whose ancient Kingdom dominated the
grasslands of os The Tall Man At first
scorned the horse Lords as uncivilized
barbarians which they were
but car mango had United all of them
into one kisar with one aim to trample
the world beneath their Hooves and take
other people's as their herd one by one
the cities of the tall men were
overwhelmed still they wouldn't unite
against the
Dothraki many didn't believe the tales
of the rare survivors no Army could move
so fast or strike so quickly they didn't
know that the Dothraki live in the
saddle and have such command over their
horses that they seem to have four legs
not two where most archers fire from
foot the dothi fire from horseback
charging or retreating it makes no
matter they are just as deadly but the
Dothraki prefer close combat howling for
blood as they ride down their enemies
with their araqs and there were so many
of them when car Mango's son car Moro
laid waste to the waterfall city of
sathar renaming it the place of wailing
children the tall men finally realized
their Peril led by a high King they
assembled a great Army to break the cars
once and for all and met the dothi on
what would ever after be known as the
field of
crows the four cars commanded almost
80,000 Horsemen between them The Tall
Man had 100,000 foot soldiers 10,000
armored Riders 10,000 light Horsemen and
6,000 sthe chariots as battle was joined
the Earth shattering advance of the tall
men's chariots smashed through the
center of the daki horde the spinning
blades on their wheels slicing through
the legs of the dthi horses when one car
went down before them cut to pieces and
trampled his cisar broke and fled the
Chariots thundered after the fleeing
Horsemen and the high King and his
armored Riders plunged in after them
followed by their foot solders waving
their Spears and screaming in Victory
but it was a trap the brai were not
fleeing as the tall men realized when
the hor Lords suddenly turned their
horses and Unleashed a storm of arrows
two more cisar swept down on the tall
men's flanks but another attacked them
from the rear cutting off their Retreat
completely in circle the high King and
his mighty hosts were destroyed the tall
men had stood for thousands of years now
the crows feasted on their corpses as
the Dothraki squabbled over their
valuables the common wisdom is that the
the dothi tide finally broke upon the
spears of the unallied at quor saving
esos from the horse Lords in truth the
days when the Dothraki could threaten
the entire world had already passed the
great cisar forged by car mango had
splintered into a dozen hordes after the
death of the last great Carl and the
Riders had resumed their petty feuds the
grasslands of esos are now called the
Dothraki sea but no more Nations
drowning
still the Dothraki priestesses the do
khen prophesied that one day the
Dothraki will gather ADV doth their holy
capital and unite once more under the
greatest KL of them all the stallion who
mounts the world he will lead their
people to the ends of the Earth and
Grind All Nations to dust beneath them I
knew aisi who the priestesses said would
give birth to this stallion she didn't
no doubt that Doos Ken had made the same
Prophecy Before and will again World
Conquest is an alluring dream but few
who dream it ever wake to its
reality